das kommt jetzt unerwartet ein neuer
fachartikel sorgt für großes aufsehen in
der informatik er besagt dass computer
jedes problem wirklich jedes problem in
vertretbarer zeit überprüfen können das
ist die wohl größte erkenntnis des
jahrhunderts in der computerwissenschaft
und löst absolute begeisterung in der
fachwelt aus und von den expertinnen
weltweit hat wirklich niemand mit diesem
ergebnis gerechnet krieg zum science
fiction hier gibt es täglich spannendes
seines videos abonniert den kanal und
aktiviert die glocke nur waren
verpassten nichts los geht's herzlich
willkommen wie andere wissenschaftler
innen versuchen auch informatiker in
dinge zu kategorisieren dabei ort und
man in der informatik probleme nach
ihrer komplexität komplexität heißt in
dem fall wie aufwändig ihre berechnung
bezogen auf eine ressource wie zum
beispiel zeit oder speicherplatz ist
computer können bestimmte aufgaben sehr
einfach lösen bei solchen aufgaben
wächst die zur lösung nötige rechenzeit
poly nominal also langsam mit der länge
des problems an
solche probleme gehören in die
komplexität klasse p
dann gibt es noch probleme die schwer zu
lösen aber einfach zu überprüfen sind
sie gehören in die komplexität klasse np
so eine aufgabe kann man sich wie ein
schwieriges so doku rätsel vorstellen
wenn es gelöst es kann man leicht
überprüfen ob die lösung stimmte und np
sind nur zwei beispiele für komplexität
klassen von denen die
computerwissenschaft mittlerweile eine
ganze menge hierarchisch aufgestellt hat
sie werden geordnet von sehr einfachen
bis hin zu extrem schwierigen klassen
eine der großen offenen fragen der
komplexität theorie war immer wie
kompliziert ein problem maximal sein
darf damit ein computer es in einer
polygonalen also einer angemessenen zeit
überprüfen kann bisher denn jetzt
scheint einem computerwissenschaftler
aus sydney der durchbruch des
jahrhunderts für die informatik gelungen
zu sein
wissenschaftler an der university of
technology in sidney stellt die these
auf dass sich rein theoretisch selbst
die schwierigsten probleme der
informatik in angemessener zeit lösen
die komplexität klassen haben eine lange
geschichte seit den 1970 er jahren
versucht man sie immer feiner zu
unterteilen eine größere komplexität
hängt dabei vor allem von der
überprüfbarkeit der probleme ab bei
manchen aufgaben wächst sie nicht mehr
polygone sondern exponentiell mit der
länge eines problems also es wird immer
komplexer komplex um solche hoch
komplexen probleme zu klassifizieren
wurden in den 1980 er jahren interaktive
beweis systeme eingeführt diese beweis
führer sind sozusagen allmächtige
computer die eine unendliche
speicherkapazität haben unendlich lange
rechnen und jedes problem lösen können
diese theoretischen beweis rechter sind
aber nicht vertrauenswürdig und man
braucht einen weiteren prüfer um seine
angaben gegen zu checken das ist
wiederum ein realistischer computer mit
begrenzten kapazitäten der das ergebnis
nach rechnet das extrem lang und
kompliziert sein kann stellt der prüfer
den beweis führen verschiedene fragen um
sich so vom wahrheitsgehalt der lösung
zu überzeugen computer
wissenschaftler/innen fanden heraus dass
die lösungen manche aufgaben nur mit
dieser frage strategie überprüft werden
können noch komplexere probleme kann man
lösen indem man gleich mehrere beweis
führer einsetzt die sich während der
aufgabe austauschen dürfen
doch sobald der prüfer ihre ergebnisse
untersucht werden sie von einander
getrennt da der prüfer ist einfacher hat
wenn er mehrere instanzen befragen kann
kann er auch eine extrem komplexe
aufgabe in polen nominaler zeit
überprüfen
diese gehören zur komplexität klasse m i
p
nach diesem ergebnis route die
komplexität theorie erstmal bis forscher
sich fragten was passieren würde wenn
sie als beweis für quantencomputer die
berg quantenphysik aneinander gekoppelt
sind einsetzen würden
der quantencomputer brachte eine
bedeutende wendung weil er neue
strategien ermöglicht um die lösung von
computern zu überprüfen hier kommt das
phänomen der quantenverschränkung zum
tragen bei dem zwei räumlich voneinander
getrennte teilchen informationen über
ihre eigenschaften ohne zeitverzögerung
austauschen können wenn zwei beweis
führer miteinander verschränkt wären
könnten sie ihre antworten miteinander
abstimmen 2012 überrascht in der
computerwissenschaftler
was will ich vom california institute of
technology damit dass man mit
verschränkten quantencomputern auch alle
probleme aus der klasse m i p in polen
nominaler zeit überprüfen kann
demnach ist sie mindestens genauso groß
wie 2009 10 kam die nächste wendung die
physiker andermatt arian vom california
institute of technology und shaun wright
vom massachusetts institute of
technology entdeckten dass die
quantencomputer klasse m stern sogar
noch größer ist als mp doch wie groß die
klasse tatsächlich ist blieb erstmal
offen die frage lautete um wie viel
besser lassen sich lösungen überprüfen
wenn man verschränkte quantencomputer
befragt es scheint die menge der
aufgaben maximal zu vergrößern
jetzt zeigten forscher in einem aufsehen
erregenden fachaufsatz dass mp stern
alle berechenbaren probleme der
informatik enthält ihrem beweis nach ist
mwp stern identisch mit der riesigen
komplexität klasse r
diese enthält alle entscheidungsprozesse
also aufgaben die mit ja oder nein
beantwortet werden können
die ein computer in endlicher zeit
beantworten kann computer können also
tatsächlich jedes problem in
vertretbarer zeit überprüfen
diese erkenntnisse sind schon höchst
bemerkenswert doch sie wirken sich nicht
nur auf die informatik sondern auch auf
die mathematik und physik auf sie
stellen sogar dass ein rettungs
problemen des fields medaillen
preisträgers allen konz aus den 1970 er
jahren in frage und dadurch auch weitere
hypothesen die von ihm abhängen die
arbeit ist an sich schon unglaublich und
dazu beweist sie auch noch dass die
komplexität theorie kein gebiet ist das
nur für sich steht wie oft behauptet
wird sie hat auswirkungen auf andere
bereiche wie zum beispiel die
theoretische quantenphysik das hatte
wohl keine wissenschaftler in erwartet
auch scott erickson von der university
of austin zeigte sich in seinem blog
überrascht zitat ich kann mich nicht an
eine einzige person erinnern die das
erwartet hätte jetzt hängt alles davon
ab ob die arbeit einer prüfung durch
unabhängige experten standhält wenn sie
das schafft dann handelt es sich dabei
um die größte überraschung des
jahrhunderts für die formate schuldiger
katze 2.0 neue klasse von
quantenzuständen entdeckt anklicken
anschauen und was sonst klicks um
science-fiction abonnieren also bis dann
bleib dran